Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad and
I am Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and today is inheritance.
What you can move on to the next
generation and what you can't.
Now the Sweden story from
our last segment, us both
feel a little strange. Yeah.
Because while you might have
a lot of influence, you know,
genetically speaking over
your kids and their kids,
you don't seem to have a lot of control.
So we're going to leave you with a
story from our producer, Pat Walters,
about one woman's radicle even troubling
attempt to regain that control all they
come on in again, a few months ago,
pat made his way down to North Carolina
to a small suburb outside of Charlotte
to visit this family. Me and
mom is the one I'd come to see.
She and I snuck away from the
children into our office. Right.
This is nice and quiet.
Um, well I guess, um,
I was thinking we could just start
at the beginning. What year was it?
Where were you? Oh, okay. Um,
1989. So this is Barbara, Barbara Harris.
I'm the founder and director
of project prevention.
And in 1989 when the story
we're telling now started,
she was living in California, in
Orange County, and I was a waitress.
I worked for IOP for over 30 years
and she was a mom to six sons.
She and her husband. Really Harris.
What did he do for a living?
Surgical technician. Six boys is
a lot of boys, but at that point,
just two of the six boys were
living at home, Brian and Rodney,
and they were seven and eight at the time.
And Barbara found herself returning
to a thought she'd kind of always had.
She started to wish again that
she could have a daughter. Yeah.
And by this point,
she's 37 years old and I knew the only
way I was going to get a daughter was if
I went and became a foster
parent and asked for one
[inaudible].
So she did. She filled out the forms,
went through all the training that we
had to do and first day fingerprinted and
had a background check done
[inaudible]
and then they waited for the call.
I already knew that if I
ever got a little girl,
I was going to name her destiny.
[inaudible]
and um, that summer it was, um,
July they got the call, I
had asked for a newborn.
So when the social worker
called me, she said,
I have this cute little baby girl
for you, but she's eight months old.
Is that too old? And I said, no,
no, that's okay. She said, well,
she's just beautiful. And she
has lips that like a baby doll.
That's what I remember her saying.
So Barbara and her son got in the car
and drove across town to the foster home
where destiny had been living for
the past eight months since birth.
We went to the foster home and went in.
The lady knew why we were there
and destiny was in the other room,
might sleeping or something, I'm not sure.
So we talked to her for a little
while and at a certain point,
the social worker pulls out a
stack of papers with a child.
They give you a whole folder full of
information and tells you all about them.
And she told Barbara, there's something
you need to know about this baby.
And she is born and tested
positive for PCP, crack and heroin.
And um,
doctors would later explained to Barbara
that Destiny's mom had been addicted to
drugs while she was pregnant.
And the psychologist who gave destiny
her first checkup told Barbara that she
was delayed and she was always going
to be delayed because of her prenatal
neglect. Did that scare
you at all as like, I mean,
that would seems like a thing that
would be kind of frightening. No,
it didn't scare me because she says as
soon as she saw destiny and sat her in my
lap with her little dress on
and her little curly hair,
she just knew this is my daughter.
A couple of days later I had
already bonded with her so much.
It was as if I gave birth to her.
Honestly, I think it never seemed, yeah,
like she was anything but my
real mom, if that makes sense.
This of course is destiny.
She's 22 now and she's never even
met her birth mom. No, I knew,
Barbara says they've reached out to her
many times, but they never heard back.
And Dessie says she doesn't
really care. I mean at all.
I got these jeans from somewhere,
but I kinda feel like she was a surrogate.
Like she carried me for my real mom.
That's how I've always looked at it.
You know, my mom needed a girl
and she got one. It's just,
that's just how I've always been.
And even though they look basically
nothing alike, I mean, for one thing,
barber's white and Destiny's black,
they both say that they actually often
forget that they're not biologically
related. They told me a bunch of
these stories. One of them involving,
well,
yes. So I don't have the
biggest boobies in the world.
You can't see that on the radio. But Hey,
it's a fact of life. And destiny says,
one day she and her mom were in
the car and her mom said, she said,
I don't know. You know, maybe. I mean,
maybe they'll grow picker like minor,
bigger and you know, and
then she goes, oh wait,
I didn't give birth to you.
That doesn't matter. Nevermind.
You're stuck with small boobies.
Okay. Now I just had to accept it,
but we're getting ahead of ourselves
here because given that really sets the
story in motion,
the set of events happened a few months
after Barbara had brought destiny home
when they got another call from the
social worker saying that same mother,
Destiny's birth mother had
given birth to another child.
Yeah. The social worker called and told
me the mother had given birth birth.
Mother's name was actually the same
as me. So Barbara Really? Yeah,
she has the same name as me.
So she'd tell me Barbara had had
another baby and a boy did we want it.
So I went to the hospital
and picked him up.
And you picked him up right
from the hospital? Yeah.
And as soon as she got
there to pick him up,
she could tell that something was wrong.
He wasn't little happy baby because
when a woman uses heroin while she's
pregnant, the fetus gets hooked on it too.
Two for Isaiah being born
with like just cut off
and he was going to
withdraw light bothered him.
Noise bothered him as it beat
it out. This is Smitty again,
projectile vomiting because
he couldn't hold formula down.
He'd fall asleep and just wake up
screaming and he was just [inaudible],
you know, most babies, Ocala peaceful.
He was never a really peaceful and
day after day, literally for months,
Isaiah would sleep and he would
scream. That was it. It was just,
no baby should have to come
into the world like that.
And nobody has a right to do
that to a baby. But a year later,
the social worker called again saying the
mother had given birth to a baby girl.
Did we want her? This is the same
birth mother. Yeah. And again, Barbara,
thanks. Come on. But if
this little girl is here,
she should be with her brother and
sister and so she should be with me.
And I called my husband
again at work and said,
they want to know if we want to
take the baby and he's a barber.
I'm not buying a school bus because we
had already had to upgrade from a car to
a van from a condo to a
home. And so I said, okay,
well this'll be the last one. We'll
just get one more. But a year later, no,
she gets another call, another little boy.
That's how we ended up with four of them.
These are four kids from
the same birth mother?
Yeah. Wow.
So by now it's 1994 and
Barbara is thinking,
I just don't get it. You know,
like how did this happen?
How was this woman allowed right
to walk into the hospital and drop off a
damaged baby and just walk away with no
consequences over and over
again. How dare you do this?
The way she sought the state, the
federal government, somebody should say,
you're not doing this.
You're not leaving this hospital
unless you have longterm birth control.
Barbara tried to get a law
passed requiring just that,
but it failed and when I found out
the bill didn't pass, I just thought,
I have to come up with something else.
I have to be creative. And she says,
one day this idea just came
to her. She was thinking,
everybody's motivated by money.
So
can I offer these women money to
use birth control? In other words,
could I pay women who have drug
problems to stop having babies?
I decided to have a press conference
in my front yard to announce what I was
doing and my naive mind, I didn't
have a clue what a big deal this was.
[inaudible]
the story exploded. Barbara Harris,
his solution is simpler than
anything else out there.
Instantly she's offering
$200 $100 200 bucks.
It's 300 down to any drug addicted woman
who will agree to have no more babies
and I'm going to go out into the streets
and offer addicted women money to use
birth control. This could
mean sterilization. It
could mean getting an IUD
if she gives the woman a choice.
If you've already had a kid,
you can be sterilized and if you haven't,
you can choose to have an IUD or an
implant put in which will last for several
years late. And when you say
they can choose to be sterilized,
do you mean permanent? Yeah,
permanent like tubes tied.
Sounds bizarre, but it's a
solution here. It says her program,
children requiring a caring community
or crack crack and prevent thousands of
unwanted births to drug addicted women.
I'd like to everybody to meet please.
Yeah.
Barbara Harris, please welcome Brian.
As Barbara made the rounds on the
daytime talk shows the reaction was split
right down the middle and the one hand,
she says immediately check
started arriving. This is 25.
This is 50 from all over the country.
This is 750 and 200 all over the
political spectrum from Hollywood,
lefties to social conservatives
together pledge more than $150,000 to her
program. And that number, by the
way, has grown a lot. That 1 million.
Uh, yeah. Over the past five years.
If you look at our tax return. Wow.
But along with the support came attacks,
particularly as drug addicted women began
to sign up. Barbara Harris says she's,
I convinced more than a
dozen women, 14 women,
25 women have accepted her offer to
be sterilized in return for money.
Right away.
People accused her of targeting women at
their weakest moment and enabling their
drug abuse. You know what they're
going to go do with that money.
You get them $200 each, but they can
spend on crack if that's their choice,
but the babies don't have a choice.
Barbara started finding herself on
panels with women who'd use drugs during
their pregnancies and that's when things
would start to get out of control.
They should all be sterilized.
Sterilize, like you said,
were like you said when you ran
your advice and like she is,
I didn't say I'm God. She
asked my opinion. Okay,
this lady right here is still taking
drugs and try and be pregnant again.
First hear about this. What
goes through your mind?
I think I was really horrified and
terrified. That's Lynn Paltrow.
I'm executive director and founder of
national advocates for pregnant women.
Lynn has become one of Barbara's
fiercest critics and full disclosure,
she's Robert Sister's partner. Well, her,
her explanation is that these
women are having in her terms,
litters of damage, babies and society
forever will be responsible for them.
She said letters in this magazine
Article Barbara Even said, quote,
we don't allow dogs to breed.
We spay them. We knew drew them.
Yeah. I'm not saying that
these women are dogs,
but they're not acting anymore
responsible than a dog in heat.
Are there people whose drug use is so
out of control? They can't parent. Yes,
but creating an assumption that there is
a class of people who don't deserve to
procreate, who aren't worthy.
Appropriating the human race leads you
down a path that is is we should have
great concern about that path is
basically called eugenics. Well,
I named Hitler thought that if you
were Jewish that you had given up
the right to be mother and he
sterilized people as well. Well,
I just want to eliminate drug addicted
babies from being born. I mean,
I don't think that puts me in
the same category as Hitler.
What's the worst thing you've been
called by one of your critics?
Probably Racist.
I'm married to a black man,
so that was just funny to me.
And according to Barbara, the majority
of the women she pays are white.
Do you think like Badass Barbara about
some of the things that she'd said?
Because to be totally honest,
they kind of turned my stomach. I,
I like you. I get the sense that like
you have, there's a lot of warmth in you.
You're obviously a great mom,
but that feels cold to me.
I was just pissed I where
they identify children now,
babies I had seen and all the people that
have called me and tell me about their
babies that were damaged.
I had everybody's abuse on my back and
I didn't care how he said it or how we
did it.
Just don't have any more children because
at that point I didn't really know any
of them so I didn't see them
as people. I just saw them as
child abusers might be a mixture,
but she says she doesn't
feel that way anymore.
After I've gotten to
know so many other women,
Barbara has this drawer in your desk and
Ms. Harrison staffer filled with dozens
of letters from women that she's paid.
I want to thank you for your support
and kindness as always. She said,
thank you so much for the gift. I
bought my son an excavator track,
remote control and some summer outfits.
This is from 2000 to whom it may
concern. I have been doing very good.
I just got got to see them,
my eight year old son and I'm so proud
and I have four years clean and I
anyways, God bless you
sincerely, Jennifer [inaudible],
have you ever had someone call or write
you and say that they regret their
decision? No,
I've only had somebody call and say they
regret that they didn't stay on birth
control, which I find kind of
hard to believe. But then again,
I must've read at least a hundred news
articles as I was reporting this story
and I didn't find a single case of
someone saying that they regretted what
they'd done.
How many women have you paid?
We have paid,
um, 4,266
that's a lot of people.
That's a lot of people. Yeah.
She actually emailed me afterwards and
adjusted that number down a couple.
A hundred and so in the end, I mean,
where do you come down on this? Right.
I ended up finding myself
really conflicted about it. The,
the, the like I agree with Lynn that this
program does perpetuate a stereotype.
Tell me what your image of a drug
using pregnant woman is. Who are they?
It'd be wrong to assume the
women Barbara talks about on TV.
It means women don't just have one and
two babies. They have six seven, eight,
10 14 yeah.
All these women who have so many babies
and never tried to seek drug treatment,
it would be wrong to think that they
represent all women who use drugs while
they're pregnant.
The women who I've worked with who've had
a history of drug problems aren't like
the examples that she gives. These
are women who love their children,
who sought help
and she says oftentimes the women who
want help a really hard time finding it
and Barbara is not offering that.
She's not offering treatment,
not offering counseling. And
there are programs that do that.
But I said this to Linde,
despite all the things that
troubled me about Barbara's program,
I feel like what she's
trying to do is to stop it.
To stop a kid from getting born
into a childhood that's gonna suck.
The fact that
that you're motivated by a, a
really beautiful, important, um,
value that we want healthy kids doesn't
mean the mechanism you're using is going
to end up helping those
kids. Because the truth is you have no
idea how these kids are gonna turn out.
Yeah. Like nobody's arguing that women
should do drugs when they're pregnant.
That is a bad way to start a kid's life.
But that's just the
beginning of the kid's life.
So much can happen after
that. Once you, you,
and for me, this whole story
really shifted, right? You at USC,
when they started spending
some time with destiny,
Barbara is 22 year old daughter. You
know, as you can see, I like to talk,
even though Destiny's mom was doing all
sorts of drugs during her pregnancy and
the doctor's told Barbara that destiny
was going to be mentally and physically
delayed, not feeling the way
I'm supposed to. She just isn't.
Could you just tell us like what you
are doing now? You're finishing college,
right? Yes. I'm almost done.
I'm graduating in December
and right now I'm student
teaching, so that's fun. But
the moment I really felt like whoa was
when we started talking about the little
baby that we
carrying in the background of
everything. That's my little girl.
She's 20 months old.
She'll be two in January.
And so her name is Kalia
and she's a complete nut.
I don't know where she gets that
from. Oh hell yeah. She keeps me busy.
Were you planning to have clear?
Nope. She was an apes kid.
She was totally new schedule. We'll
just be honest. We just didn't think I,
I just didn't think, you know, you know,
they say it only takes one time
while Yep. That is so true.
One time and a month later. So yeah,
it's embarrassing. But I believe
everything happens for a reason.
And I think that no, I didn't plan on it,
but I wouldn't take her back for
anything because she made me better.
I want her to be able to look
back on her life one day.
Maybe when she's getting interviewed,
I dunno. And be able to say that,
yes,
my mom was there for me 100% without a
doubt and I'm going to have straight A's
and I'm making it work and I'm going
to graduate with honors and one day I'm
going to be able to tell her,
look, I did this. You can do this.
Like push yourself and
you got it. That's really,
I mean you're just,
you're saying a lot of things
that are really impressive
to her. Like I matter, like
I make a difference to her.
Okay. All right. We can stop.
So we did stop and I packed up
my stuff. It's pretty much done.
And Barbara and destiny walked
me out to my carb. Kalia came to,
they had a little basketball for her.
Oh madness here.
And at a certain point I
noticed like over my shoulder,
Barbara is crouched down and she's got
her phone out and she's taking a picture
of this just perfect little scene
and you could get a here already,
you're going to kick it and do it.
I just felt like I was in one of
those moments that like, look,
I'm gonna contains everything that's
good about us as people. You can do it,
buddy, you're watching this.
I couldn't help but think that Destiny's
very existence is probably the most
interesting argument against
what Barbara is doing.
I can it back because if Barbara
had gotten to Destiny's birth mom,
destiny CLIA this moment,
none of it would exist.
Yeah, and I told destiny I was thinking
about this and asked her about it.
My situation turned out positive.
I mean as far as you know,
positives can go like I
think I hit the Jackpot.
A lot of times that's not the case
and you just had to have to weigh it.
Like is it worth it? Like I could've
turned out like some of the other kids.
Destiny says before she was born,
her mom had four other girls.
These were kids that didn't
end up with Barbara. Yeah.
Three of them ended up in other foster
homes and seem to have done pretty well.
But one of them,
okay, well one of them don't
really know what happened to her.
She's somewhere, but it's not
good. From what we've heard
last they heard she was
living on the streets in La
and that could've very easily
have been one of us. Yeah. I mean,
yes I might get a great
family but I might not.
And the question that was stuck
in my head right then was like,
if you could choose between being born
knowing that your life might end up like
that and not like it is now
or not been born at all,
what would you have done?
Um, not been born at all.
I wouldn't want to put it up to chance
because what kind of life is that?
You mean that I didn't mean that.
Yeah, I'll check the side. I know I've
been joking a lot in this interview,
but I mean I, with all that I am,
let's see. She wants to see it.
Okay.
Add the back together.
What's she saying there?
Taylor swift's never came
back. She say never ever.
No baby. Be careful just saying. Okay.
Do you want to say bye?
Hi. Okay. Bye. Say Bye.
Aw, you blew him a kiss.
That was nice. Okay. That was
okay. Still
remind me this destiny has, uh,
what three brothers and sisters
that also were raised with her?
Two brothers and one sister.
What happened to them?
Isaiah is in college and
Taylor and Brandon W I met
them at Barbara's house and
they, they seemed to be, uh, to be fine.
And what about the four kids
that weren't raised with Barbara?
Do you know anything about the other,
the other four? I just a little there.
There were four girls and Barbara and
destiny told me that a few years ago they
found three of them and they all either
were in college or had finished college.
So then the one that's in trouble, it's
just one of one, two, one of eight.
Yeah, one of eight. So I guess
you could say to yourself,
seven out of eight of these kids did it.
Right. [inaudible] that's interesting.
I mean, that's, that's a different
kind of arts, but it's, yeah.